[Music]
picasso
and modern art in general has a
has a destabilizing effect on society
and i think they meant
for it to be that so in a way maybe they
did what they did was right i think that
most modern
art and contemporary art
believes in a revolutionary vision of
reality that the purpose
that our purpose is to is to to bring
about revolutions to
to destroy the the the status quo to
destroy
the existing order and and i think that
picasso was a communist i mean he was a
communist pretty much his whole life
even
even when it became embarrassing maybe
to be so and uh
a lot of the a lot of the modern artists
were either communists or fascists
you know these the futurists were
straight on fascists you know they
wanted
to burn the old system down and set up a
totalitarian
uh you know system of art too a
totalitarian system of art we have
artists who are totalitarian in their
artistic vision
we don't we don't tend to want to see
them that way now for some reason
but uh but the uh a lot of the the the
abstract artists were
especially the russian abstract artists
had a totalitarian vision of reality
and a lot of modern designers were very
totalitarian you know
some some modern architects would say
things like
you know i wish i could design the
people in my house
or i wish i could nail the chairs to the
floor so that
i could control it sounds like excess
order exactly everything the way the way
it is okay
um and so you have these these you have
like the this
you have this these two tendencies let's
say modern art you have both you have
a kind of destructive tendency and a
totalitarian tendency which is part of
the modern world
so you see it as off balance because
yeah in peter's the petersonian point of
view which is also the dallas point of
view there's order chaos
and you see it as being on the extremes
and that they're not mediating between
the two
properly yeah i agree i think the whole
modern world
that's what it is it's just a swing it's
just this
this pendulum swing between two two
excesses and you can see it in modern
art you can see it as well
and they become confused and they kind
of fight and then they they break each
other apart
um but but it's a it is a fascinating
thing to
to see now we kind of just gloss over a
lot of it but
if you look at the way for example that
even post
um abstract expression is art
uh let's say manifested itself it
started with this
freeing up you know jackson pollock
throwing paint on the ground and
and kind of this chaotic energy and
everything and then it ended
with color field painting where it was
like just
strips of one color and you couldn't do
anything else like it was
it was uh completely everything was
controlled in these extremely
tight tight boxes of what you could do
and i saw this painting that was just
white
with one speck of red do you know that
painting i forget it's a
large it's a very famous painting yeah i
don't know which i don't know which
painting you're for that
okay just imagine a blanket yes i can
imagine that and then there's some
splotch of red in the corner yeah and it
sold for millions of dollars
is that contemporary yeah well that's it
depends it could be
uh it would probably be a moderate we
probably consider it modern or late
modern you could say
contemporary arts tends to be more uh
cynical
and and we'll take modern conventions
and be more playful about them
and will create a kind of parody for
example uh
german artists like uh richter who is an
abstract artist but his abstract art is
considered to be a kind of
parody of abstract art where it's a it's
almost like a comment on
abstract art it's not directly abstract
art it looks like abstract art
with a kind of photo kind of weird photo
uh lack of focus in it and there's a lot
of
neo-abstract artists who are actually
there's a kind of weird cynicism to what
they're doing but it gets very confusing
contemporary art right now is just a
giant ball of anything like it's very
difficult to know there is post
post-modern or at least
i think no i think that we have i think
that what i'm doing is
is could be considered post-post-modern
and
i'm part of a group let's say of people
who have
grown up in contemporary art who learned
contemporary art
several who are who had a promising
contemporary art career ahead of them
you know they had
they were in galleries they had um they
had different
scholarships and everything to big
schools but then they kind of came to
the end of the
kind of say like they came to the end of
the carnival at some point the carnival
has to end
you know at some point you've eaten
enough pie
and you're you know you've had enough uh
you had enough
pizza had enough pizza exactly you had
enough sugar and
and and blinking lights and so
what ends up happening is a rediscovery
of
what i would call traditional art and i
and i see that you see that
so so i know several iconographers who
make icons for churches
who who had that exact turn where they
came to the end of contemporary art and
they realized
this is this is just nihilism it's just
nihilism on steroids
[Music]
you